hatim n'est pas professeur il fait
partie des entrepreneurs sélectionnés
pour participer un nouveau dispositif
lancé par l'incubateur ski cube à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines gérant d'une
entreprise d'audiovisuel il reconnaît
avoir besoin d'être pour se lancer dans
le monde entrepreunarial rejoindre cette
formation parce que j'ai déjà une
entreprise en fait j'ai une entreprise
en audiovisuel dans le cinéma
et du coup j'ai rejoint cette formation
parce que je me suis lancé il ya un an
dans ce dans ce milieu là sans aucune
base sans aucune formation aucun
accompagnement aucun entourage ce qui
fait que j'ai fait j'ai commis
énormément d'erreurs il ya énormément de
lacunes de dont je suis conscient
d'avoir et pour moi cette formation
représente également l'opportunité en
fait d'avoir ce d'obtenir cette attaque
cet encadrement d'avoir les les
vérités si on peut dire ça comme ça du
savoir des des experts
au total 14 entrepreneurs ont été
sélectionnés sur les 50 candidatures
reçues ce dispositif propose des cours
collectifs et individuels des sessions
de coaching et de l'immersion en
entreprise une formation mise en place
par l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et l'association les déterminer
on avait aussi envie de
dynamiser le tissu entrepreunarial nos
petits entrepreneurs et notamment ceux
qui sont éloignés
des réseaux traditionnels
d'entreprise et donc ça a été l'ambition
de notre partenariat avec les déterminer
cette première promotion on a la charge
de deux d'accompagner les trois
premières semaines des créateurs
d'entreprise de la formalisation à la
posture entreprenariale au développement
du projet et après on a un jour par
semaine d'ateliers on va venir faire du
renforcement on va venir faire de
l'individualisation
sur certaines thématiques pour les
entrepreneurs en tout cas moi ce que
j'ai vu ce matin c'est une des hommes et
des femmes qui sont extrêmement
déterminé la formation durera quatre
mois pour se terminer le 17 décembre